pastor Mellie transit Ingram puts in a  triple fine to make a move Nellie will  trail it on top for Ingram inside room  out taken by the Phoenix Suns 96 they  open things up with an eight nothing off  the beautiful hustle I shot outside  buying from contact Ingram over Johnson  everybody hitting those shots Devin  Booker Holliday defending here comes  Tyler Johnson inside we kept it inside  beautifully by Ingram what an attention  plum or picked up by over a guitar  Johnson is hunting brother rocket van is  here Ingram single shot points this  quarter for Ingram here's the fadeaway  against the smaller holidays got 23  Ingram will drive into two and get it to  go  what a play by Brandon Ingram and then  the quick move baseline fills the  contact user for general and holidays  7-nothing run for New Orleans see this  is good  JJ reddick shot the ball so well that he  took to Whitney right off of that